pays oui et beau merci madame évidemment
la parole et à monsieur patrick hetzel
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre nous examinons en ce
moment le projet de loi finances
rectificatif pour 2016
c'est un exercice traditionnel en fin
d'année toutefois la nouveauté c'est que
ce collectif budgétaire propose 5
milliards d'euros de crédits
supplémentaires par rapport à ce que
nous avions voté pour le budget 2016
ces dépenses supplémentaires portent
essentiellement sur des soupes
budgétisation massive dérapage des
dépenses de personnel etc
explosion des dépenses de l'aide
médicale d'état et cetera vous
financiers le tout par effet d'aubaine
sur des économies sur la charge de la
dette et sur le prélèvement au profit de
l'union européenne
cela pourrait paraître anodin mais c'est
en fait très grave d'abord parce que
nous savons que les taux d'intérêt vont
inévitablement remonter ensuite parce
que vous avez ouvert les vannes de la
dépense en cette fin de quinquennat ce
qui met en péril la tenue des objectifs
de déficit pour 2010 est en somme vous
lécher une dette massive aux français et
à vos successeurs
vous serez donc une nouvelle fois bien
largement au-dessus des 3% du pib prévu
par maastricht à cause de votre
incapacité à respecter la trajectoire de
réduction du déficit
enfin parce que vous avez d'ores et déjà
grevé le budget 2010 8
ainsi la prochaine majorité devra gérer
vos 12 milliards d'euros déjà dépensés
et dont le coût sera supporté en 2018
alors que les recettes manqueront à
l'appel en raison des crédits d'impôts
que vous aurez distribué dès 2017 comme
cadeaux électoraux et lâche plus rien ne
nous étonne avec vous mais là cela
dépasse tout entendement
c'est de la cavalerie budgétaire au
terme de ce quinquennat nous aurons
toujours une dette galopante
alors quand aurez-vous le courage
monsieur le premier ministre de dire la
vérité à nos concitoyens sur nos cours
d' public très largement déficitaire
merci la parole est un monsieur
christophe sirugue secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
et zèle il semble que je me souvienne
qu'elle en fin de l'année 2014 qu'à la
fin de l'année 2015 vous ayez entonné le
même discours sur l'insécurité
budgétaire la réalité à montrer monsieur
le député que les résultats de l'année
2015 et les résultats de l'année 2016
corrobore à la fois les éléments
d'appréciation qui ont été portées par
le gouvernement pour la composition de
ce budget est en même temps bien sûr la
sincérité budgétaire que vous semblez
mettre en cause aujourd'hui vous
interroger sur le projet de loi de
finances rectificative en essayant de
laisser à penser finalement que nous
serions encore dans l'état d'esprit que
vous dénoncez qui pour autant chaque
fois a été démentie nous avons je le
crois
rétabli des fondamentaux parmi ses
fondamentaux il y a bien évidemment le
respect que nous avons mis en place du
des objectifs que nous nous donnons un
objectif de 3 3% que nous atteindrons
pour ce budget est un objectif inférieur
à 3% que nous atteindrons également
l'année prochaine nous faisons cela et
je rappelle que le haut conseil des
finances publiques a dit que ces
objectifs étaient à la fois atteignable
et réaliste cela montre bien le sérieux
à la fois des prévisions qui sont celles
du gouvernement
en même temps les sérieux de la
commission qui travaillent sur ces
enjeux et que je veux saluer pour ces
éléments là et donc monsieur le député
je veux vous rassurer sur les craintes
que vous exprimer mais dont je comprends
qu'elles sont un élément de discours
dans une campagne électorale mais
qu'elles ne correspondent pas à la
réalité de la situation financière
merci monsieur